-We've had many guests
on this show.
I've never seen
half a standing ovation.
[ Laughter ]
-That's pretty solid.
-That's not bad, no.
-That's about as good
as it gets.
-It really is -- It's almost
as good as it gets.
A full ovation would be probably
-That's pretty solid.
You know what?
I'm going to disagree with you.
I think a half ovation is
as good as it gets.
[ Cheers and applause ]
A full ovation is like, "No,
they cued them to all stand up."
That's, like,
the hard-core fans.
Like, "Oh, they actually
did it."
It's not --
[ Cheers and applause ]
-But maybe I didn't even give
you like a --
Maybe if I really upped
your name or something,
they'd give a full ovation.
-You know what?
I don't want the full ovation.
I want the half.
It's quality, not quantity.
-Wait, but have you seen --
-Quality, not quantity!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Quality, not quantity.
-Have you seen
the other half stand?
-I don't want them to stand.
They sat. Stay seated.
[ Laughter ]
Commit.
Commit to your disinterest.
[ Laughter ]
I don't give a [bleep]
-Oh, my -- Hey, hey!
-Bleep it! Bleep that!
[ Laughter ]
-You've got a lot going on, Jon.
You're coming in hot tonight,
man.
Dude, you have a lot going on.
You're in the new series,
Amy Schumer's new series
"Life & Beth."
-Yep.
-You're also on "Law & Order."
-Yeah, I'm on
"Law & Order: SVU."
-Yeah, "Law & Order: SVU."
[ Cheers and applause ]
-"SVU."
It's Jon Glaser Douchebag Week.
[ Laughter ]
I generally seem to play
[bleep], so yeah.
-That's weird.
Because you're such
a funny, nice guy.
-I'd like to think so, but it --
Sometimes I question like,
"Why am I so good
at playing a total --"
I'm gonna swear again --
"a total [bleep]?"
Right?
[ Cheers and applause ]
Bleep it! Bleep it! Who cares?
-Stop saying
"Bleep it, who cares."
Don't curse anymore.
-Also bleep when I say "bleep."
[ Laughter ]
But yeah, so I seem to excel at
playing a douchebag and --
-Bleep it. Who cares?
-Bleep it!
[ Laughter ]
That's gotta be --
-That's another character.
-"Just bleep it."
-"What are you gonna do?
Bleep it."
-"Hey!"
-"Bleep it!"
-"Hey, bleep it!"
But can we talk about which type
of an A-hole you play
in the Amy Schumer show?
[ Laughter ]
So, the piece of [bleep]
that I play in...
[ Laughter ]
..."Life & Beth,"
he works at a vineyard.
His name is "Gare-old."
[ Laughter ]
With a hard G.
-Gerald, not Jerald.
-Not Jerald. It's Gerald.
He's got a goatee and, like,
a rat-tail ponytail.
[ Laughter ]
That he's always kind of, like,
making sure he pulls around
his neck,
and he's playing with it.
-Yeah, I -- Oh, that's perfect.
That's perfect.
-Pretty enjoyable.
-I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Jon Glaser and
Amy Schumer in "Life & Beth."
-Okay. How can I help you?
-Uh, I have an appointment with
Jerald, the wine manager.
-Uh, "Gare-old."
It's pronounced "Gare-old."
-Gerald, okay.
-And, well, Gerald is me.
-Oh, well.
-And, as you can see, I'm with
some customers right now,
so if you can just be a little
patient, I'd appreciate it.
-Sure. I'll wait right here.
-Uh, actually, uh, this section
is for customers only.
So if you don't mind waiting
outside, it'd be a big help.
-Okay?
-You know, I'm not really sure
what your school of thought is,
but for me,
customer is never wrong.
But you city people don't really
understand that, do you?
-Okay.
-'Cause you're just so special.
-No time for other people's
stories.
-I'm just going to wait.
I'll wait out there.
Thank you.
-Thank you.
That'd be great.
How we doing on that Pinot,
guys?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-And how were they doing
on that Pinot?
They're getting around to it?
-Pretty good, yeah.
-Good, yeah.
-How did my half of the audience
love that?
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah!
-How did the other half of
the audience think about that?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I don't even give a [bleep]
[ Laughter ]
-"Bleep it!"
-Come on, bleep it!
[ Laughter ]
-What in the world, man?
-What are you gonna do?
Bleep it.
-Oh, my gosh.
You've done so many funny roles,
but this "Law & Order: SVU"
is a dramatic role.
-This just kind of
came out of nowhere.
And I was very excited to do it.
And one of the fun things was
that they asked me
to dye my hair blonde.
Which was pretty enjoyable.
And there's a photo.
[ Laughter ]
And so, I still have the hair,
which I'll show right now.
-Wow.
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Oh, yeah.
I'll put my Detroit Bad Boys hat
right there.
-Yeah, that's where it goes.
-I don't know if you want to get
a shot of that.
-No, we don't. We don't want --
-Yeah, you do!
-No, we don't want to get a shot
of that.
-So, yeah, so I got to go --
-Wow, you look cool.
-See, that's the thing.
I love it.
I know it looks ridiculous.
I think it looks cool.
My wife hates it.
But I didn't want to then just
get rid of the hair.
So I've kept this
for the last month.
[ Laughter ]
And I've been thoroughly
enjoying it.
I know it looks dumb.
I'll take it to my grave
that I look cool as [bleep]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Bleep it! Bleep it.
-B.I.!
-But anyway, so, I told my wife,
I'm like,
"How about just,
when the episode airs,
then we'll cut it?"
And then this came up
just this weekend.
And I thought, "Let's just do
this more spectacularly."
I brought some scissors.
[ Cheers ]
Yeah.
-I'm honored.
-I want you to be the hero
to my wife,
and I want you to cut
the blonde -- I'm not --
This is tough for me, but let's
just -- It's time for it to go.
-Are you sure, Jon?
-Yeah, let's do this.
-You want me to do it,
I'll do it.
-But here's the thing. Hold up.
I want you to like --
It can be a hatchet job.
-Oh, it will be.
-Do this.
[ Laughter ]
-I don't know what I'm doing.
-Leave a little bit
in the front.
Leave like a unicorn horn...
-Alright.
-...that I can take home to my
wife, and then she'll do that.
-Jon, this is --
-Yeah.
-I can't believe
you're letting me do this.
You want to see it
or you don't want to see it?
-Oh, sure. Let me take this home
to my wife.
I'll put it in my Bad Boys hat.
[ Laughter ]
Now, you know what's going to be
really nice?
You know, the show airs later,
so while tonight,
my wife and I will be
making love.
[ Laughter ]
And we'll put the show on.
We'll make love to the image of
you cutting my hair.
[ Laughter ]
-Why are you telling me this?
I don't want to know
these details at all.
I'm going to bleep that.
-And then hopefully
we'll achieve simultaneous
orgasms at the last snip.
-Alright. Here it comes.
-Get the back.
-Here comes the -- I almost want
to leave the back
a little bit, too,
if you don't mind.
I just want to get
the last snip.
Jon, I think I did a good job.
In fact, I think I did
a great job.
I left a little -- I left
a little madness in the back.
If you want to just turn
sideways.
Just turn sideways.
Yeah, that's good.
So, I left a little madness.
I think that looks good
right there.
We always love having you on.
Enjoy tonight.
Jon Glaser, everybody.
"Life & Beth" premieres
this Friday on Hulu.